[Music]
all right today's question comes from
joanna in oregon i've been married for
two years
and we never combined our finances i'm
self-employed and expect to make fifty
thousand dollars this year
my company is in my spouse's name even
though he does not contribute anything
to the business
he distributes the money after i make it
and withdraws twenty percent for himself
we recently discussed having children
and he said i would have to save to make
up for my lost salary during maternity
leave just as i would for anything else
that i wanted
i am crushed i feel stupid betrayed and
trapped
he holds all the cards so where do i go
from here
basically her husband's stealing from
her right
this seems messier than it's written if
i'm reading this just at face value i
would
go get an attorney tomorrow i mean it
sounds like this marriage is over it
sounds like she's being held hostage
there's got to be more to it than this
yeah the the language that she's using
it has him at such a level of control
that i worry about him hitting her too
oh this this just
screams abusive it screams toxic control
yes crazy she's not allowed you know
pick her own
lipstick color type stuff you know this
is just strange
my name goes on your business that you
work at and that you pay me from
yeah and you give me a tithe because i'm
the
guy the guy tax yes the guy tax and if
you want to go do things like i don't
know have a kid
then great you can you don't have to you
have to pile up you know you have to be
able to take care of that because i
can't have my
lifestyle i can't you can't affect my
husband tax
or my lifestyle yeah my expectations all
that money you make for me
right i mean dude this sounds whacked
yeah something's not right here but if
this is me i would go see an attorney
tomorrow
i don't know i don't know another way to
do this because this this just reeks of
major problems here's the thing joanna
he does not hold all the cards
the only thing he holds is emotional
control over you
and uh he doesn't really have much legal
control because that business that you
started and he has to be put in his name
uh divorce court will undo all that and
they'll probably hand you the keys the
whole thing but certainly andrew keys to
50
of it anyway so he's not in as much
control
as he thinks he is or that you have
allowed him to have
and so that that's the thing he's
he doesn't hold all the cards now and no
you do not
need to have a child no not not in this
situation
uh now say so i i'm going to do two
things i'm going to go ahead and contact
a
a marriage and family therapist a
marriage and family counselor
and you go talk to them and invite him
into that conversation and i
also would go and have a consultation
with an attorney
the attorney will teach you what i'm
telling you
that uh he does not hold all the cards
the marriage and family therapist
can sit down with you and unpack
long-form what's going on here
and may just simply reinforce what
john's saying and that's activate the
attorney
or they may say there's a glimmer of
hope here and if he did
these five things then we could save
this and we
with amount of work uh called counseling
marriage counseling then um
you know maybe this is saved and maybe
we talk about kids down the road
but uh but no kids right now that not in
this situation the way this is written
is written as if you're being abused
it's it has abuser language
that's what i'm reading that's why
you're that's why you're activated any
time i yeah i'm
dave you can probably feel me seething
here i i i hate this scenario
whenever i hear somebody say crushed and
stupid and betrayed and trapped
those words together tell me somebody's
literally trapped well somebody's
feeding her that word that's right
she doesn't feel that way on her own
she's been those are those are actual
emotions
right that she she taught she's been
told
that she's owned and she believed it
it's got too much domestic violence
language in
it and so now if he is
joanna i'll i'll escalate if he's
hitting you
uh you can play with that if you want to
i don't think i would i'll just be done
with it
um if you were my daughter
um there'd be other things involved
but aside from that i'd be telling you
as a part of the other things i'd be
telling you to get away
i'd probably drive you too that way you
don't get caught in a crossfire so
probably
drive you to the attorney yes yeah well
and you know
just call the homicide detective over
some but yeah but
uh yeah we'll call granddad that's right
we have ways of dealing with you boys
but um
yeah that's uh that's old school but the
uh yeah i
um yeah you don't you don't you don't
you don't
this is wrong everything in this
language that you wrote honey is
is bad and you're worth more than all of
this and
so get some help get an attorney get a
counselor
get a good pastor in your corner get
some community around you
you are not trapped you are not stupid
uh you are betrayed uh but that's just
confirmation
anybody sitting out there listening to
this that feels this way
crushed stupid betrayed trapped go talk
to somebody
dave you said it best you're you got one
tiny quick life
and man you're worth more than spending
that
life feeling stupid and betrayed and
trapped go talk to somebody whether it's
a marriage counselor whether it's a
pastor it's an attorney whether it's a
friend that knows your story
god man go take action you are worth
more than
being trapped i hate it
when if he he's obviously in some kind
of bully mode
yeah at a minimum and um
the the bullies are not um
they're never made happy by you going
along
no it puts gasoline on a fire yeah and
so
the only thing you can do is set
boundaries and separate yeah with a
bully that's all you can do
and then they can decide with those
healthy boundaries in place
are they going to continue or are they
going to heal
whatever's broken inside of them that's
causing them to be you said it right
they have to heal and often folks who
find themselves like joanna on the other
side of this
think they are contributing to the
healing of somebody else and you're not
no that's called codependency that's it
yeah you are
you are ugh you are trying to
throw sand into a hole that can never be
filled that way man
um he's gonna have to do his own healing
he's got to decide there's really one
thing you can do with domestic violence
let's get away from it yeah
that's all you can do yeah that's it and
once you get away from it
then both parties have somewhat of a
chance of putting
something together that looks like
health yeah but at least you stay alive
and you're not a punching bag anymore
and this has again
all of let's get away language yeah you
know a thousand years ago i think i've
told you this um
i don't know if i said it on there or
not there was an old show called sally
jesse rafael oh yeah i remember that was
on that show several times and they had
an
on-staff counselor that would come on
the air with us a lady
and i got to talking to her off and she
showed me this piece of research
all this data where someone is a super
hyper controlled with the money
the husband is there's a high
correlation with that and domestic
violence absolutely like he wouldn't let
her buy the
certain serial every little detail hyper
control it's financial abuse yeah
well it's all it's correlated with him
physically using it as a punching bag
and it's just it's it's a real indicator